we're going to talk about them trying to
take out our boy rogan
yeah before we have this talk who is
joni mitchell
that's what i need to figure out real
quick joni just got bangers johnny loves
chachi yo you ain't even yo [ __ ] uh
what's the [ __ ] canuck what's his name
no
whatever the [ __ ] with a horse with no
name that wasn't even him that was
somebody else somebody better somebody
less cuckish
in the free world oh that song sucks
dude oh that was america that song sucks
songs
[Laughter]
oh misinformation shut your ass up dog
you see what sagar posted what did he
say people who sign up for amazon he's
going to give them like free months free
of amazon music or some [ __ ] i think he
planned this [ __ ] from the job four
months free yeah well the conspiracy is
i was talking to sagar a little bit
about it i think there's this uh hedge
fund that owns the rights to neil
young's music which is a call like
blackstone
oh yeah they're trustworthy and uh
basically uh you know they also have
some investments in pfizer and some
other places like every single hedge
fund so i'm not gonna say that there's a
lot of truth to this but there could
potentially be and they could be and
maybe they could be deeply invested in
amazon for all we know so maybe what
they're saying is hey
you're allowed to do this we're not
going to give you any pushback because
one it's going to help with our pfizer
stock because they're not going to be
constantly talking [ __ ] about the
vaccine and two it's going to push some
people over to amazon so sometimes it's
not like there's a few people in a room
you know cooking up this conspiracy then
calling up neil young big neil it's time
to pull the music it's more like neil
does it and then the company that owns
the music goes yeah this isn't too bad
for our interests right right right
and then we could capitalize and get
four free months that's exactly possible
so there could be something there what i
think is so interesting about like the
rogue and cancellation thing is that
the media the traditional media the
corporate media machine um is
trying to cancel rogan for
misinformation which is the exact thing
that causes us not to trust the
corporate media machine yeah so you were
trying to cancel rogan for the reason we
don't watch you it's a complete lack of
like self-awareness right like if they
actually like i don't think people want
to go watch a podcast for truth i think
people want information in the easiest
way possible right they just want to
turn on [ __ ] cnn or turn it on fox
turn on msnbc tell me what happened tell
me the truth they don't want to seek out
some guy who's on the [ __ ] internet
talking to doctors and [ __ ] that you
have no clue who they are i mean half of
these guests that come on rogan right
now we have no clue who they are yeah we
just know they're experts in these
fields correct right we want information
distilled to the easiest form of it so
we can digest it and get on with our
[ __ ] day and we would like both sides
of an issue which the news will never
give you absolutely but the fact that
they keep on [ __ ] up and putting out
their own misinformation we go through a
list of misinformation that they've put
out right
um is the reason why rogan exists and
they keep on putting more and more
misinformation out there and not
acknowledging their mistakes yeah and
there are many of the mistakes and rogan
keeps getting bigger and the fact that
they can't see that is so confusing to
me because it's almost as if they're
going hey if we get rogan out of here
people will come back to us no you get
rogan out of here another version of
rogan is going to replace it because
they lost faith they mean us we lost
faith in you
and i've i met rogan twice he's the
nicest most well-intentioned guy i may
have ever met in my life i promise if
somebody replaces him he's not going to
be as nice or well-intentioned because i
just don't know that you can be a
hundred percent cause he does he doesn't
want it he's not doing this for power
he's not going oh i'm gonna find a way
to manipulate the masses into doing
something it's like if you thought
everything that was wrong with like [ __ ]
culture or whatever was paris hilton and
then the kardashians came you know what
i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what it's gonna be it's just so
funny that they think that like getting
that guy out of here could potentially
help them it's like it's not gonna help
you you're the [ __ ] problem yes
correct you're the issue it's like
someone who can't stay in a relationship
and then just like keeps on breaking up
with girls and it's like it might be you
buddy
you might have issues that you have to
fix within yourself yes in order for you
to have a successful relationship it
might not be the hundred girls that you
dated yeah maybe it's you
and it's shocking that they can't just
realize it all we want is to feel like
we can trust the person giving us
information that's all we want and the
fact that rogan constantly goes out
there and goes yo i got it wrong like he
just admits it
if he gets it wrong he goes out and
admits it he tweeted a clip of him
getting something wrong that not only
did he tweet he could have edited it
from his podcast all together he put it
in there shout out the guy who
proved him wrong yes 100 journalists
australian journalist i forget his name
josh maybe something doesn't make it
doesn't matter but the fact is he shouts
out the guy who gets away he says he's
getting these things wrong he says he's
learning about it he says i don't
[ __ ] know anything i'm asking these
questions and i'm doing my best to get
all the information out there as i can
and then he goes and he has this he has
this like uh i don't know what do you
want to call it like a kind of it's not
an apology to me but it's more like um
he said whatever he said he said very
well but what do you call that he kind
of addressed everything yeah he
addressed the issue
and it was just brilliant dude yeah
because in that moment when you have
the media and the political apparatus
both attacking you
and wanting you out of there it's very
easy to get bitter and angry yeah and
the most beautiful thing about the video
is you can't watch that video if you're
being objective and not like the guy i
love neil young i like joni mitchell
i have a cool neil young story
i don't still support him and it's not
passive aggressive it's not like yeah i
love neil young but he hurt me don't say
that he literally goes
it's so strange to be in my position
yeah and i'm doing the best i can yep i
didn't ask for this and i didn't know it
would be this yeah and it's a really
strange feeling that [ __ ] brutal
honesty dude honesty and authenticity is
the hot knife
yeah it is the hot knife and the rest of
this [ __ ] is the butter dude it cuts
right through somebody just going guys
maybe what i could do is have other
experts with uh differing opinions on
right after
so we could get a more fully formed
version yeah and i'll be honest a lot of
those [ __ ] don't want to come
on
a lot of those [ __ ] don't want
to come because they don't want the
pushback yeah they don't want to push
back on their ideas of things they're
putting out i mean look what happened to
sanjay gupta yeah right dude got [ __ ]
bodied mm-hmm i mean he even said in an
episode on tim dillon's pod he was like
yeah i'll have on immediately i would
hunt i'd love to have fun without you
and never
he would [ __ ] ever because they know
that they're spitting the [ __ ] and
they don't want any pushback look what
happens when charlemagne has kamala on
gives her one little bit of pushback
immediately her handlers come in trying
to take her off the podcast it's a
national news story et cetera they
thought that they were going to go on
charlemagne's show and get softball
[ __ ] questions yeah and charlemagne
came with the reel i bet you that's the
last time he gets to interview kamala
that's the last time you get to
interview biden so these people are
upset
when the real questions are being asked
to them and then they avoid interactions
where those real questions are going to
present themselves and then they just go
on cnn or msnbc or fox news or whatever
these shows are that just regurgitate
the same talking points that they tell
them to say and it's funny you can hold
him accountable for something that he
acknowledges he made an error on and
stuff like that and then the cdc and i
look i do believe in the vaccine but the
cdc for a fact misled us early on and
lied to us and said hey mass don't work
and then mass became everything and they
did that so we didn't buy up all the
mass but you intentionally misinformed
us and nobody wants to hold them
accountable for that
again i don't think everything i say is
[ __ ] but if we're gonna hold people
accountable rogan makes mistakes they
lie to you have lied to you at least
once yo you want to know some real [ __ ]
when rachel maddow came out and she said
that um if you get vaccinated you can't
get the virus and you can't uh pass it
on to anybody else right we could easily
go to her and be like yo you spread
misinformation you should be canceled
and that was wrong from the moment when
they said it they said 90 efficiency or
effectiveness true true true but what i
want to say what i would say to her
specifically is or about that situation
is i don't want a cancer
maybe that was the information that she
got
from her experts and at the end of the
day she's not a [ __ ] scientist just
like all these people that are
criticizing rogan aren't [ __ ]
scientists okay you maybe got a
journalism degree of [ __ ] syracuse
right you don't know any more about the
virus than he does matter of fact you
probably know way less because you're
not speaking to these experts in their
field all the time so i don't want
rachel maddow cancer for that i would
like her to acknowledge that she was
wrong so that we could continue to trust
her with information right but i don't
want her cancer she trusted the experts
that were talking to her
rogan is platforming experts let's not
act like these guys are some like quack
doctors these people are experts in
their field and these are their opinions
right so now we just have different uh
differing opinions and then we as human
beings have to choose who we believe
yeah and then roll the dice on that
could he bring those experts on right
afterwards sure would that give a whole
picture sure maybe that'd be safer etc
but for the traditional media
to act as if they're doing something
monumentally different than him is
absolute [ __ ] yeah and they're
trying to get him out of here and it's
it's the same
[ __ ] story every single time
like their strategy is the same every
single time
make the guy radioactive
it's literally this it's like any time
he does something they don't like it's
the same story look how racist he is
look how sexist he is look how
transphobic is every movement that they
try to spread it and i want to expand on
that because this is their version this
is how they do it okay they make you
radioactive so the platform takes you
down so they don't have to deal with you
and if the platform doesn't take you
down and this is what they're going to
start doing now because it's the same
story every single time what they start
doing is making your fans radioactive
so that you don't identify as a fan
if they can't de-platform you right they
can't
get the people to shame you they shame
the core that supports you right they
make the core
the
the the transphobic racist misogynistic
[ __ ] and that's what they're
starting to do i just saw a clip of some
chick on cnn oh what i'm worried is
about the the rogan fan harassing me at
work or the rogan fan putting my life in
jeopardy now they've shifted to the fans
and human beings
have the feeling
in us all that we want to fit in to our
peer groups we want to be at work and
people like us we don't want to be
ostracized we don't want to be on the
outside
and that's like a biological yearning
because back in the day if you were on
the outside of your tiny little tribe
you're [ __ ] dead you needed your
people to protect you in order to stay
alive none of us want to be ours
ostracized none of us want to be alone
so we stop identifying with that group
in order to maintain the peers right to
make living that much more comfortable
and easy and that's what they're going
to start attacking and that's why it's
important that we speak up about it
yeah because this is the same story
every single time and if it's not rogan
it's gonna happen to someone you [ __ ]
love it might happen to [ __ ] us and
if we're quiet right now why should
anybody speak up when it happens to us
yeah and i think even just as dangerous
is just the idea that like
like sagar not talked about this shouts
to sagar but he was saying like you know
they're not you can't cancel chappelle
you can't cancel rogan they're too big
they're gonna cancel guys like us i
don't know that that's necessarily true
because i think authenticity does win
out but i think this idea that anybody
who disagrees with you has to be
censored is bad for the country yeah i'm
not we we'll make our money we'll be
fine but this idea that if you don't
agree with me you can't talk and that's
how we're going to progress as a country
is not how we're going to progress as a
country period it's just going to have
more and more different americas until
we just [ __ ] hey we're done with this
thing yeah this this this illusion that
you know
this information or this misinformation
could cause death it's like all of a
sudden you guys care about
misinformation causing death weapons of
mass destruction with misinformation
millions of people [ __ ] die because
of it right
now all of a sudden you care about
misinformation cause and death yeah
right oh you had positive you were
positive uh edoc had weapons of mass
destruction right now they're no no that
was nothing how many hundreds of
thousands of troops had their lives
ruined if they didn't die ptsd whatever
it's not just weapons of mass
destruction it's how we got into [ __ ]
vietnam yeah the gulf of tonkin incident
it's constant misinformation causing
hundreds of thousands of people to
[ __ ] die whether they're ours or
somebody else's so don't give us this
[ __ ] like you care so much about getting
the information right or else people
will die you lie every day so people die
because the people who tell you to
[ __ ] lie
you listen to no matter what the cost
i i just i i yeah i hate it man
it just drives me crazy yeah i wish they
understood that a lot of the
overreactions we see are because of
their response the way they handle
things like yeah a big reason a guy like
uh i'm not trying to get too political
but trump gets elected and a certain
percentage of people are just so [ __ ]
tired of being shouted at and being
shamed because you're a white dude or
whatever that one guy that comes along
is like bro i don't care what else he
says he doesn't make me feel bad for
being a white dude i like this guy yeah
the same thing is going to happen with
alternative news sources i can't trust
these guys they're shouting at anybody
disagrees with them they're also [ __ ]
slanted i'm going to go to alternative
news sources you always create this and
then you try to silence them it's not
going to work yeah they're reaching so
hard one guy was like the thing that
disturbed me most about rogan's
statement this is all they had was he
said he doesn't prepare for his
interviews you know who didn't even know
[ __ ] about his guests when they came on
wanted to know as little as possible
yeah larry king the greatest interviewer
in history the history of this country
also that's cap i'll call rogan out on
that he is prepared
he's reading he is taking in information
about these people especially if they
come on like if they just had a book
he's reading the book he might have
already finished the book or he has at
least started the book like the guy
knows and the guy is because he actually
[ __ ] cares yeah it's actually
impressive to be that wealthy and like
wanting to get into the minutiae stuff
yeah it's easy when you have money to
[ __ ] chill i actually do remember
listening to an episode recently maybe
tim dillon where he said he's he's
always reading about the guess he's
having on but even if he didn't that
doesn't mean anything he just wants to
dude larry king is a fantastic
interviewer and he's like i don't want
to know about the guest i just want to
talk and see what happens yeah and he's
a journalist an actual journalist you
expect a [ __ ] comic yeah to to be
different than him and why that's a bad
thing i just don't know i'm okay also
with the disclaimer in front of the
episodes i don't think that's the
biggest deal no this is uh appeasing the
idiots the idiots think that they gotta
want a win absolutely nothing changed
everybody's quote unquote happy happy
until they can find more reason to
cancel him the problem with what's going
on right now is that
he's been positioned as the new trump in
terms of media we've spoken about this
on a podcast before where like the left
needs to put out opinion pieces and by
the way like i don't want to turn this
into like a left right [ __ ] thing i
think one of the great things about
rogan the reason why he's so hard to
cancel is because the left and right
both listen to him the extremes might
not that he might not be extreme enough
for all but the left and right are into
him they support what he's doing and
they value what he has to say right okay
even if they disagree with him maybe
they just agree with on the vac [ __ ] or
maybe they disagree with him some kova i
disagree with him on some things i'm
still listening you should yeah i
shouldn't agree with him on everything
yeah otherwise i'm the idiot yes you
should have your own opinions about it
yeah if i listen to any one person
everything they say and they're not god
i'm wrong i'm a [ __ ] absolutely and
you do disagree with god you lit you
know believe in your goofy [ __ ]
right
instead of the real guy
you don't even know if you believe in
god i do believe in god [ __ ] ass
agnostic well i'm not sure how i feel
about it yeah i do believe in god yeah
yeah yeah when when you're about to
crash in a plane no
[ __ ] no i do believe in god
i'm being serious which guy agnostic is
believing in a higher yeah i believe in
a higher power i just don't know which
religion is right i'm weak [ __ ] that's
weird that's weak
but why is it weird
putting on my eyes like you made your
decision
like you chose which guy you believe in
i stuck with it is that good you're
msnbc
oh i'll be taking a new information
that's why i love my religion because it
takes in new information oh yeah it
changes with the time which information
yeah which information
he used he used a nuclear bomb on me
dude
is now acceptable in my religion
okay wait where were we though where are
we who knows
point is you can disagree with rogan is
still oh yeah i don't know you should
yeah and that's okay and i think that we
got to this point where like
if you believe
and this is the intolerance on both
sides okay but if you believe that
everything you are doing
is righteous
right
then disagreeing with that righteousness
is actually evil and wrong think about
that if you have no malleability when it
comes to your beliefs you believe not
only is everything you're doing right
but it is
virtuous
if you disagree you must be a horrible
human being why would you disagree with
virtue yeah you must be bad right so of
course they're going to position it in
that way
right but the reality is that's not how
the world works nope and you're not that
righteous
i mean look in a mirror a hundred
percent 100
all this smoke for rogan
they're like they're like we're taking
our views off we're taking our listeners
off spotify right
and then they're like you should go
listen to to our albums on apple right
oh yeah and it's like like that company
yeah it's righteous ethically sourced
sweatshops yeah
yeah yeah yeah like what are you talking
about known slave labor yes right known
slave labor i'd rather you listen to my
music on the slave phones or amazon
where jeff bezos is a scrupulous uh
individual who pays his fair share of
taxes i don't know what scrupulous is
good or bad
that's good it's moral yeah
[ __ ] man that was a tricky one dude
that's awesome because i was getting so
excited because you felt so good
okay i thought that was a slur i thought
i thought you were just going crazy me
too that's nice
um what are you guys thoughts i thought
the coolest part of his uh like face to
camera video was basically taking
responsibility for everything even
though like he could have not you know
what i mean like he had one thing where
he's like i'm doing all this myself like
i'm trying to get gas i'm doing
everything like he didn't try to hide
behind a booker he didn't try to hide
behind like producers like people you
know bring someone on and i just got to
figure it out like he just manned up and
took responsibility for the whole thing
yeah i this is all me and i'm doing my
best yeah it's like the i thought like
the best way to handle it yeah i think
the only person that's allowed to be mad
at rogan is the guy that got the [ __ ]
beat out of a at a neil uh young concert
and he left
he just left his job halfway through and
just drove home oh yeah like what
happened to that guy yeah
yeah he's got the [ __ ] yo where's
security can someone help me right now
is this payback from neil young
you know he left neil young's concert
and he was like i'm leaving you that's
what it is yeah [ __ ] you security yeah
yeah 40 years later we're missing one
guy yeah is alan morgan started learning
jiu jitsu he was like i've got a
security job i can't fight these
grappling i gotta [ __ ] fire
yeah yeah screw this what are you
thinking al i agree with mark and i just
like how they handle it in terms of the
putting the label on it it's a win-win
on everybody's side yeah like one side
thinks they won because they got some
out of it this doesn't affect rogan at
all and now you can actually probably
bring back the old episodes that they
took off the platform because now you
can just put the disclaimer on it and
now we can watch the older stuff
you